طب هذا العاجل ايضا لايذاء الاسرائيليه
تؤكد جيدا وقاء انفجار اخر دون اصابات قرب
موقف حافلات اذا جنوب القدس
الغربيه كنت قد تحدثت عن اجراءات يتم
اتخاذها من قبل الاسرائيليين واغلاق مداخل
المدينه هل همم نتوقع بما اجراءات سيتم
اتخاذها من قبل السلطات الاسرائيليه همم
بعيده يعني وقوع هدينا الانفجارين
[موسيقى]
بتبيعه الحال همم
كنت اتحدث عنه خلال المداخله ان هناك
انفجار اخر هو المصادر الاسرائيليه تؤكد
ذلك همم يعني حاليا تصل ايضا بان الشارع
الرئيسي الذي يصل بين مدينه تل ابيب
ومدينه القدس جزء كبير منه تم اغلاقه وهذا
الشارع هو الذي يؤدي الى المدخل الرئيسي
لمدينه القدس حيث وقع الانفجار صباحا هذا
اليوم خلفيه الانفجار الثاني ما زالت قيد
السلطات الاسرائيليه بطريقه
التحقيقات حول
ملابساته بمعنى انها تقوم حاليا بمراقبه
همم كاميرات المراقبه في المنطقه وقتها
وايضا تقوم به استجواب شهود يعني كانوا في
المنطقه همم يعني احد شهود
يعني افاده حتى هذه اللحظه مؤكده بان
العبوه او حقيبه بها عضوه ناسفه تم وضعها
على دجاجه ناريه بالقرب من
الحافله وسرعان من انفجرت الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه عاده تبدا بالتحقيق وبطبيعه
الحال هذه ستكون في حاله انك تاكد من ان
اشارك فلسطيني
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وايضا في مدينه همم
القدس همم التحديث الاخير من المصادر
الطبيه الاسرائيليه حاله اثنين من
المصابيح الاسرائيلي توصف بالحرجه
ومن مجمل الاصابات نقلت الى المستشفى
بالاضافه الى المستشفيات الاسرائيليه في
مدينه القدس هذا بالاضافه الى عده اصابات
همم
لانها حاله
ايه اذا 10 اصابات في الانفجار الذي وقع
صباح هذا اليوم في مدخل مدينه القدس عند
محطه
للحافلات ونتحدث عن منطقه حيويه للغايه هي
المدخل الرئيسي لمدينه القدس من الجهه
الغربيه
للغايه تحديدا في سعاده الصباح حائر في
هذه المنطقه توجد محطه الحافلات المركزيه
لمدينه القدس والحاليه في هذه الساعات
يكون توجه لي العمال والموظفين وايضا
تحديث المحطه التي فجرت عندها العبوه
الناسفه يقال بانها عاده محطه مخصصه
للجنود الاسرائيليين او يكون بها العديد
من الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين يتواجهون في
ساعات الصباح الى المعكرات التي يخدمون
بها همم
الاسرائيليه تواصل اغلاق المنطقه بالكامل
تغلق مدخل القدس من الجهه الغربيه
تم ايضا اغلاق مقطع من الشارع الرئيسي
الذي يسمى شارع رقم واحد وهو يفصل بين
اييه او يوصل بين مدينتين
والقدس ااه الشرطه ايضا تقوم بعمليات بحث
وتمشيط في المنطقه بحثا عن منافذ او
مشتبهين بتنفيذ هذه العمليه
يتواصل مع الاسعاف ايضا نقلات المصابين
تحديدا التي توصف حالتهم بالحاجه والصعبه
الى المستشفيات الاسرائيليه وتتواجد هناك
ايضا لمنع العلاج لمصابين اخرين تحديدا
بحالات وحالات همم الخوف الشرطه بدات
باشراء تحقيقات عن جامعه كاميرات المراقبه
في هذه
ملتقى وبجمع شهادات من شهود عيال حول
ملابسات ماء جرى والتوجه الاولي يفيد او
تتوجه الشرطه نحو وضع عبوه ناتفه حقيبه
كان بداخلها عبوه نافذه على دراجه ناريه
انفجر في هذا الموقع في ساعات التربه في
ساعات الصباح في هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن 10
اصابات
بحاله حرجه نقلت هذه الاصابات الى
مستشفيات مدينه القدس الى جانب ذلك وقع
بعدها بنحمل النصف ساعه انفجار اخر ما
زالت الشرطه الاسرائيليه صفحه خلفيه هذا
الانفجار في منطقه اخرى في القدس في
مستوطنه
المحتله ولكن حتى الان همم لم يبلغ عن
الخلفيه بعد والحديث
الاول بانه لا يوجد اصابات وانتشار الثاني
همم نعم